the University of California at Berkeley
is said to be bracing that's the quote
bracing for conservative speaker Ben
Shapiro is upcoming appearance at their
campus the university announcing free
counseling threatened by Ben Shapiro's
visit the LA Times publishing an article
many are comparing to hurricane
preparations and the question is have
you satisfied your deductible or do you
have to pay out the money should you
need the counseling Ben Shapiro joins us
now he's the editor in chief of the
Daily wire syndicated columnist and host
of the Ben Shapiro show Ben what is it
about what you say that forces children
to run for counseling well I mean first
of all look at me I'm just period of
physical intimidation
it just shows then how much they need
you there I mean these kids are going to
counseling it's like grow up get get
some thick skin you need to be there
speaking and teach them a thing or two I
mean as I've said before if you if you
feel like you need counseling for my
speech you probably need psychiatric
help in some way so I guess that's
appropriate when I talk about in these
speeches as I talk about the fact that
violence in political settings is not
appropriate which you would think would
be basic civics 101 and I also talked
about the idea that in America you're
living in the freest country in the
history of the world and there aren't
people out there trying to stop you and
say should stop talking about how
society is setting up institutional
obstacles and you should stop worrying
so much about so called white privilege
you should instead focus on what you can
do as an individual to better your life
and if you see instances of racism an
instances of sexism or homophobia or
bigotry all of us stand with you if you
can name the instance but you can't
actually just sit there and blame
America for all of your problems sure
and we understand you're going to be
talking a little bit about that radical
leftist group and Tifa but ultimately
don't you think it's not that they don't
want to hear about Antipa they just
don't want to hear from a conservative
guy yeah that's exactly right one of the
things that's been really shocking and I
think it's one of the reasons why you're
seeing even some folks on the Left who
are disconcerted by this is that an Tifa
and the hard left are calling me at
white supremacists right I mean Orthodox
Jew who was literally the number one
target of the so-called all right white
supremacist in 2016 according to the
anti-defamation league they're saying
that yeah I was some sort of part of the
the Trump fascist regime first of all
Trump is not fascist but beyond that you
know the notion that I am a part of the
Trump administration is absurd I
actually didn't vote for Trump or
Hillary in the last election cycle but
just shows you how far the left is off
base when they decide that everybody who
is the right of Bernie Sanders must be a
fistic threat to the United States
wearing Nazi uniform whereas Jill Stein
was happy to get your support and didn't
want to speak to this group if they if
they feel this way about you why gulp
well I'm not speaking to the group
that's actually protesting me but you
know I spoke at Berkeley last year and
there was no problem whatsoever one of
the reasons that it's imperative that
conservatives go to Berkeley is to
demonstrate that this is not going to be
a fascist town run by people like Ann
Tifa I mean it's a free country
Berkeley's still part of the United
States and the First Amendment still
applies by there's incredible demand for
conservative speakers there we were
given a 2,000 seat theater before they
sliced off the top half of the theater
and said that nobody could come because
they were afraid and he was gonna come
literally rip bolted chairs off the
floor and hurl them down into the
audience so they took a thousand seats
away from us but we sold out a thousand
seat theater in 40 minutes I mean we
easily could have filled the four or
five thousand seat theater there so
there's clearly a demand for dissenting
views in what is a pretty monolithic
area one person tweeted out that you're
a category 5 hurricane someone else's
the LA Times said their headline was
Berkeley bracing for the right-wing
talk-show host Ben Shapiro's visit and
then this was in the the campus
newspaper the Berkeley newspaper it said
we are deeply concerned about the impact
some speakers may have on individual
sense of safety and belonging no one
should be made to feel threatened or
harassed support services are being
offered and encouraged you mentioned all
the violence I want to get your reaction
about that and if you are expecting
violence why do you want to put yourself
in the middle of that so as I say I
think that the Berkeley's expecting
violence the City Council last night
approved a resolution finally allowing
police to use pepper spray against
violent protesters which shows you where
Berkeley is that they weren't allowing
the police to do that before but they've
set up a cordon apparently a hard cordon
around the auditorium where I'm speaking
the shut down six buildings including
the Student Union now they say there's
gonna be a very visible police it's all
insanity yeah Ben what is your message
for parents who are considering sending
their children their young
adults to four-year college where you
only get one political point of view for
four years what what sort of person
comes out at the other end of that well
if you're not a conservative at 18 then
you will be leftist by the time you're
21 if you move into that machine I've
always said that it's a good testing
ground for conservative ideas I think
the people who are really disadvantaged
by the leftism of universities are
people in the middle and people on the
left because they never hear a
dissenting point of view but if you're
on the right like I was I mean I went to
UCLA and I was right-wing and I was
however law and I was right-wing I
always thought that it was a neat thing
yes I got to test out my ideas and test
them against the best the left had to
offer the problem is that if you're on
the left you never hear anybody with a
different point of view and so you come
up with this notion that's been imbibed
wholesale by the Democratic Party that
everybody on the right because you've
never heard of right-wing argument
everybody on the right must be a Nazi
and Nazis are worth punching right
unbelievable Ben Shapiro the human
hurricane the tornado that is the
natural disaster that may be thanks so
much for joining us that's a lot like
stay safe